i am laura garcia curiel
and i'm going to present my project
of the omis logic bioinformatics
research
fellowship program i'm a phd
student in food science and human health
in universidad autonoma del estado de
hidalgo
in mexico
so i have completed many courses in both
platforms in omis logic and in
t info
so in this slide i'm just showing you
and the courses i i have already
completed
and they are about introduction to
bioinformatics
genomics metagenomics and
transcriptomics
and i have completed other courses
such as pca biomedical data
visualization in
r and the last one
that was the one that
made an impact on me and it's called
machine learning for the medical data
so i was really interested in machine
learning
in python and in this project
i developed a machine learning a
tool to a classification purposes
so as an introduction to my project
i'm going to classify bacteriosines
so bacteriosines are antimicrobial
peptides
that are produced through ribosome
synthesis
and their produces about many bacteria
as
uh mechanisms of competition
in in complex environment
so bacteriosims have
many classification shims but
they are most classified in three
classes
for the purposes of this
of this research of this project i'm
going to focus
just in class 1 and class 2
bacteriophins
because a class 3 bacteriophins are
heat level peptides and they have
not many applications in food
or in health problems
so i'm going to focus just in class one
class two
bacteria things
so uh class one bacteriosines
are mainly antibiotics but
we have in this classification other
molecules
that are posterous nationally and
modified but
in this world i'm going to focus on
antibiotics
only so these antibiotics
have a mechanism of action and
they they pinned
to lipid two in the peptidoglycan
membrane of gram-positive bacteria
and they form porns so
um they
have these mechanisms of action and
class
ii bacteriosines have a different
mechanism of
action these peptides
are subclassified in other classes
and they they form pores
but they don't bend to lipid too
they bind to other receptors such as
mam pts receptors
they can make also membrane
depolarization
and pore formation
so these bacteriophanes
are not a modified
and what it what is interesting about
antibiotics
well
well these peptides uh as i already told
you are modified by ends
in sims enzymes um
they can be modified by lamb bc
that is uh they they retaste and land
sea
that is acid class
and or they can be modified by a single
enzyme that is called
lan m that is an enzyme that
have that has both a
activities the hydrates and the glaze
and this is a important
this is important because they
form rings
they form metal antennine rings that
are a that are important in the
mechanisms of action of these peptides
also antibiotics means to lipid too
but in different parts of
lipid too and this
feature
this feature is important because these
peptides don't develop
resistance as quickly as for example
antibiotics and they can be good
candidates
for a for
antimicrobial peptides
well another important thing in my
in my work is the properties of the
amino acids
of these peptides so we have
here a slide of amino acids
and we have these amino acids classified
by for example non-polar or aliphatic
amino acids
well these amino acids are hydrophobic
and for example glycine it's an example
of this
amino acid and we have then
aromatic amino acids that
can participate in hydrophobic
interactions
for example tryptophan
then we have polar or on church
amino acids and
and these are more soluble in
in water or are more idophilic
then we have
amino acids like glutamic acid and
aspartic acid
and then we have basic amino acids
and these amino acids but well are
positively charged
so that that is important because in my
project
i'm using the properties of amino acids
to make that classification
so in this slide i'm showing you some
difference
in sequences both for
antibiotics and for non-antibiotics
peptides so here in this slide
we have four antibiotics we have four
boat
for lamb bc modified peptides and four
lamb m modified peptides in this slide
you can see
that the difference in the sequence
are conserved based on the enzyme that
is modifying the peptide
for example in lamb bc modified peptides
we have
uh there release some peptides like
nissin u and it
has f nlt motif
there that is conserved in these
peptides
um and then we have plan m
modified peptides and these peptides are
characterized for having a double
glycine
motif in the urine sequences
so this is just for a streptococcus i'm
showing you here examples of
streptococcus
bacteriosines and their sequences
but it happens for
all antibiotics
then we have in this slide difference in
sequences
for a class ii or not antibiotics
peptides
and we have that
some of them have a conservative
that is a y g n g
v and this mod type is
conserved in class 2 a bacteriosines
and we have other classes of peptides
some peptides
are are conformed
by well some bacterias are conformed by
two peptides
and and we have here an example
thermophiline 13 and mutasin
iv they are two peptides
so this is just an example for you to
see
how is a sequence of these
peptides so
for making my my data set
i use bagel for
bagel form is um
a platform where you can search
for for these peptides you can search
for them
and find um some features of these betas
like the sequence or or other
other things that are contrasted
experimentally most of the cases
so i i get
from there a sequence of ribs
or class 1 bacteriocenes and
i get a heat of 682
and then for class 2 peptides
or not antibiotics i get 231
so for ribs i just want to focus on
antibiotics
i don't want to focus on other
post-traumatic national
posteritational um
modification such as
and your peptides orbatromicin i don't
want to focus on them
so i just include the ones that
were classified as lentipeptide
antibiotic and class one lentipeptide
so i get a total
of 232 heats
and then for class 2 bacteriophins
i discard 10 incomplete records
uh these records hadn't that
the complete sequence or
yes they were not they were not complete
so i discard it manually
i do all of this in excel
and and after that i
i convert the csv file
to a fasta file in order to
make or to clean my data
i use a cd hit this program
is used to discard sequences that
are very similar and that
and that can
have problems when you
when you make your machine learning
model you can have problems if you use
very similar sequences so
i discard sequences with more than
a 95 sequence similarity
and after using this
this cd heat i get
a total of 182
antibiotics and 182
not antibiotics and in that
in this slide i'm showing you
the length of these peptides for example
in antibiotics we have the longest
peptide is 104 amino acids
and the shortest is 22
amino acids so
this is my data for my machine learning
model
after that i decided to use a
collaboratory
that it's a google service because i
didn't have to install anything
on my computer i have problems with
compatibility
i use anaconda to manage
all all the all the features
and to use python 3. so
i use a scikit-learn to make
a random forest classifier
and for this random forest classifier i
use
80 of my data to train
the model and 20
of the data to test the model
and also make a 500
trees
also i use a p feature
view filter is a
web server to compute features of
protein and peptide
sequence although it's web server
you can you can have access
to that code in python 3 and
make this classification
for your data
so p filter has
many can can make a lot of
calculation for example it can make
it can make amino acid composition
of the world protein of of
just one part of the protein it can
predict
also the peptide composition
a tripeptide composition
and other physical chemical properties
such as
a composition of positive church
residues or negative churches charges
sidus
or neutral or aromatic
also it can make a prediction of amino
acid
index and residue
repeats index it has
as you can see many properties that we
can
compute and that we can use
to make the classification so
for this project and just like an
exercise
i use only amino acid composition
of the world protein that it's called
aac
to make the classification in
antibiotics or not antibiotics peptides
so in the next slide
this is life i'm showing you the results
of the amino acid composition
calculation
so i i make this table
using pandas and um
here we can see all the the
sequences of all the peptide sequences
of the positive data set and the
negative data set
and we we can see
that for each amino acid
a numeric bailu was a
was assigned for example in
peptide 1 that it's an antibiotic
we can or the program compute
that for alanine the composition was
6.67 and for
16 it was 5 and
the same for the other amino acids
so the object the objective of this
classification shim is that the
program can discriminate
between antibiotics and non antibiotics
based only on them
on the amino acid composition
or or this number that these numbers
that were assigned
by feature
so before making the
random forest classifier
um i make or i use
this classifier this prediction that is
called
lazy predict well this package lazy
predict
[Music]
can measure the accuracy
or others other characteristics
of many machine learning models
and you can make a decision if it's
better to use a random forest
or if you can make for example quadratic
discriminant
discriminant analysis or use
other machine learning tools
to classify your data so
here in this plot we have that random
forest classifier
has a good accuracy
so we we can use this
machine learning tool
then in this slide we have the matus
correlation
coefficient and we have that random
forest classifier
has a good mattress correlation
coefficient
this coefficient measure the quality of
binary and multi-class classification in
this case
we have a binary classification because
we are
discriminating between antibiotics and
non-antibiotics
so for the random forest classifier
we have here uh
a plot of
the true positive rape and the false
positive rate
and at the right we have a confusion
matrix
this confusion matrix is very important
in classification shims because you can
see
um how many
good or well classification your tool
made and how many false
false classifications your tool make
for example a true positive and true
negative
are a good classifications because the
machine
classified an antibiotic
a peptide that is a an antibiotic aslan
antibiotic or a peptide that is
non-antibiotic as non-antibiotic
so if the if your program
make a good classification
it can be true positive or too negative
both of them but if your
machine learning tool make a wrong
classification it can be false positive
or false net
and we have here that for well
classification
the machine learning tool or the random
forest
make 68
hits and for
but classification the random forest
make for only five five ground
hits so this random forest classifier
has an accuracy of 0.93
and a matrix correlation coefficient of
0.80
862
so and what features are of
more importance to make this
classification
in this plot we can see that the
content of cysteine and glycine
it's important to make the
classification or to make that
discrimination
between antibiotics and non-antibiotics
they are the amino acids that has
more that have the more importance
for the making this classification and
after that we have
all others amino acids
at last i'm showing you here
uh three of the 500
that were made in this machine learning
too
and well i'm showing you the
small tree
and we have there
[Music]
well here is the amino acid composition
and then we have the genie
the genie index that decrease at each
split
if the future is important
so we have this just for illustration
purposes
well amino acid composition has been
used for making classification
of these
these peptides in the past
and glycine was identified an important
feature
for for making this choice
so other projects use
[Music]
also other filters like vector machine
or sequential minimal optimization
or they they look for sequence order
effects
so this was just a small project
and
[Music]
but it can be complement but other
features
in future to make these um
to make this model more robust
and more accurate
so that is all for the
explanation of this presentation and
thank you very much